This video is made possible by brilliant.
You'll learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about the right now,
you got a brilliant.org forward slash biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description below.
My Japanese pronunciation is not brilliant,
so bear with me in this video.
I have a computer here.
I'm looking up the stuff when I can.
Sometimes I fail.
If you want to have a go at me in the comments,
go right ahead.
During World War Two,
in the second Seleno,
Japanese war dogs named Shiro issue was responsible for creating biological
weapons of mass destruction is she built a laboratory in Manchuria cooled unit
7:31 on behalf of the Japanese government's.
Its goal was to create a weapon so deadly.
It could wipe out the population of Japan's enemies.
He used nibbling Chinese villages as as human Guinea pigs for these bundled
trickle weapons and experimented on men,
women,
and even children.
When the war was over,
the United States learned about Shiro Ishii sadistic experiments.
While many of the Nazis were sentenced to death for that crimes against
humanity.
And Europe's concentration camps,
Shero issue was allowed to go free.
So what would drive someone to become one of the most evil men in history and
why on earth we see it,
I have to get away with mass murder.
Well,
that's what we're looking at in this week's by graphics.
Shiro Ishii was born in 1892 in a village called Shitty Yama in the Chiba
Prefecture of Japan.
His parents were wealthy landowners that came from a long line of Daimyos or
feudal lords,
who owns the most land in any given area.
The Japanese system of prefectures or states have only just begun in the 1870.
So his parents were very powerful and still had a lot of control over the
government and the Chiba Prefecture.
Throughout history,
these wealthy landowners benefited from indentured servants who farms the fields
and they weren't able to enjoy a lavish lifestyle even into the 19th century.
These descendants of the dime year,
we're still very much benefiting from their family's fortunes.
At the same time,
the Japanese people looked up to the emperor of Japan with a godlike admiration,
even though they logically knew the imperial family were mortals,
they still had a very strong sense of loyalty and they believe that the life of
someone living in the lower class was truly not as valuable as someone from the
optic loss.
Because of this Japanese mindset share real issue was raised to believe that he
truly was far more important than most people know much else is known about his
younger years.
Except to say that it would seem like his path seems very linear.
It is almost as if all of his life experiences were preparing him to experiment
on human beings without any sense of remorse.
Sure is.
She studied medicine it Kyoto,
imperial university,
but he wasn't interested in becoming a doctor who heals the common people in a
hospital.
He became a surgeon for the Imperial Japanese army in 1920.
One earns the rank of leftenant.
His superiors were impressed with his surgical skill,
so they sent him to the army medical school in Tokyo for further training.
They also paid for him to start doing a postgraduate medicine program at Kyo to
imperial university,
even though he did become a medical doctor,
like we said,
he wasn't interested in healing.
Patients was far more fascinated with studying and experimentation.
You had a particular love of biology and particularly bacteria.
It used to grow deadly bacteria in petri dishes and he called them his pets in
the 1920.
[inaudible] finished his many years of medical school and went on a two year
trip around the world to visit 30 countries.
He was particularly fascinated with staying in Germany so that he could study
the poison gasses that that romy used during World War One.
Chlorine gas had been used as a weapon of war,
but both sides began to use gas masks.
As far as she was concerned,
gas was no longer an effective means of killing another soldier.
In 1931,
the Chinese territory of Manchuria was taken over by Japan during these seconds.
Sino Japanese war,
and this was a huge victory for Japan and they were already occupying Korea.
They were feeling very confident that they could spread this embar to conquer
the entire rest of China.
Sure,
if she saw this new Manchurian territory is a perfect opportunity for him to
take his theoretical ideas of biological weapons and make them into a
devastating reality,
just like an evil villain in a bond movie.
He was searching for a plague that was capable of wiping out the entire human
race or at least the enemies of the Japanese empire.
At this point,
surely she had such a powerful position in the military and government that he
was able to personally approach the emperor and request the funding to create an
arbitrary in Manchuria.
Off to that permission was granted.
He built a massive compounds called unit 7:31.
It was officially called the epidemic prevention in water supply unit because
its true purpose of studying biological weapons was supposed to remain a secret.
They were given a huge budget which they spent on state of the art equipment
unit 7:31 was similar to a Nazi concentration camp and that it was an entire
campus of buildings which included holding cells,
medical facilities,
and a gigantic crematorium.
The administration building where she worked with so strong,
it was the last building left standing after being bombed.
Yes,
later,
but of course you can't have human experimentation without test subjects.
The Japanese can pace on military.
Police would grab it,
Chinese people off the streets of their villages on arrest them.
They were put on trains that arrived at unit 7:31,
and they were never allowed to see their families again.
They captured all ages of men,
women,
and even young children because they wanted to see how these weapons affected
all types of people.
According to the military doctors who worked there,
they were forced to work at unit seven,
31 without really even knowing what they're getting themselves into.
Upon arrival,
they would find doctors,
injecting Chinese people with a deadly disease like anthrax or you'd be
bottleneck plague.
If they spoke out against the experiments.
It would be treason and they could be executed for us,
for those who were forced to work in unit seven,
31,
they had to believe that this was all just a part of war and killing the
civilians was no different than bombing an enemy country.
In fact,
they believed that their actions were far more noble than the average soldier
because they killed in the name of science.
Doctors would dissect human beings while they were still alive without using any
anesthetic.
They wanted to see what organs look like while they were still functioning and
to learn exactly how the disease would cause these organs to fail.
Some of the subjects were given a vaccine to the plague first before exposing
them to the disease.
This way,
they were able to know exactly what the strongest vaccines were for the
deadliest diseases in the wells.
Once they affected the formula,
they were able to create enough antidotes for all of Japan in this way.
Unit 7:31 was making breakthroughs and modern medicine,
but it was at the expense of a great many Chinese lives.
They're holding cells.
They were large enough that they could hold up to 600 people at a time.
They called these people meritus,
which means logs,
which only further to humanize them.
The average lifespan for these prisoners was only four to six weeks when their
bodies were done being used.
They were thrown in a pile and burned in the crematorium,
in his laboratory Sheria.
She was experimenting with the Bubonic Plague,
which is known for being one of the most deadly diseases in history,
but he didn't want it to be the same place that we remember from the past.
He genetically altered it to be extremely potent and far more capable of killing
people than any previous strain of the plague.
The bubonic plague can only be transferred through blood,
so he wanted to release disease,
written fleas on unsuspecting villages in order to test how strong it truly was.
They collected ramps,
which were perfect incubators for thousands upon thousands of fleas,
and the insects were Catholic,
gathered and put into containers.
First round of experiments had airplanes dropping baskets full of fleas into
Chinese villages,
civilians,
and it worked exactly as they had hoped.
Between 1939 and 1942 plagues began to spread in these villages.
One third of the total population of each village was wiped out.
These manufactured plagues were so potent that once they were infected people
which is die within one to two days,
according to testimony by a man named Gene [inaudible],
his sister was infected with this mega plague after being bitten by one of the
fleas.
The glands in her neck was so swollen,
it was as large as a hat.
She knew that if she stayed inside and received medical treatment,
she would in fact the rest of our family with the plague,
so she had to go into the middle of a field and die alone.
Their family members could not get near her and they had no choice but to burn
her body in the field where she lay.
While baskets full of fleas have worked with low flying planes,
shearer,
she knew that if he wanted to,
in fact enemy countries,
they would need to drop actual bombs filled with fleas.
The only issue was that the fleas would,
of course,
Diane,
the explosion.
He figured out that by creating clay pot containers,
he could drop a so called germ bomb that would smash when it's at the grounds
and the fleas would stay alive,
but they didn't just stop at the bubonic plague.
They experiments with anthrax and typhoid as well.
After dropping these bombs on even more Chinese villages,
the Japanese soldiers showed up in all the white lab suits covering their entire
body.
They would command villages to come out of their homes and they would find
subjects who had been infected by the plague and performed dissections in the
middle of a field while their friends and family watched on to share issue.
It was all about gathering data and statistics.
These people,
they were just numbers on a page.
They were not actual human life stem.
The campaign were even given candy from unit 7:31 and instructed to show up to
villages and hand out the Swedes to small children.
While Chinese villages interpreted this as an act of kindness,
the Kenzie was actually laced with anthrax.
The scientists would later arrive and observe parents beginning to panic as
their children died in their arms.
As time went on,
the unit expanded their human experiments beyond diseases.
They also did experiments on frostbite and the effects of shrapnel wounds.
This involved strapping people down to a wooden plank before blowing up a bomb
next to them.
All of this was just so they could study how a human would be blown apart by
different types of weapons,
so I think now is probably a good time for a little breather.
This one's a bit intense.
I mean science.
It's responsible for the devastation of lives as we're seeing in this video,
but is also responsible for the saving of millions used the right way.
Science changes the welds in remarkable ways for the better,
and that's why I'm pleased in this video to tell you about brilliance and I know
as always,
these ads in the middle of their less than awesome but brilliance are fantastic
for sponsoring this sort of longer content because it allows us to share the
darker lessons from scientific history in a thoughtful way.
Brilliance on science learning platform that allow youtube learned through
active learning,
which summed up is basically the opposite of that feeling of reading a complex
paragraph about some principle and then just having absolutely no clue what on
earth was going on about even on the 10,
three,
and they don't just cover the basics,
although they do cover those as well,
but it goes through to really complex things like advanced statistics.
I was recently going through a course on statistics,
particularly the one lying with statistics.
It's an amazing primer on how to be aware of when the media is misusing
statistics to push your opinion one way or the other.
Brilliant makes even complex statistical concepts,
easy to understand.
They give you something super short to read.
It's very easy and then you immediately apply it to a problem and then you just
rinse and repeat that and all of a sudden you're understanding things that you
never thought you would be.
I've been using brilliant for a while.
You should just give it a go to see how easy it is to start understanding
complex subjects so they support biographics going to brilliant.org,
forward slash graphics,
and now let's get back to abusing science.
Even though Shiraishi and unit seven,
31 had developed these deadly weapons,
they never made this public knowledge or threatened to use the German bombs.
Some historians believe that if the Americans knew about these bioweapons ahead
of time,
they would have never dropped the atomic bombs on Hiroshima and Nagasaki for
fear of mutual destruction.
But if you think the allied powers were safe from the sadistic experiments going
on in Manchuria well,
think again.
Sure.
If she plans a long distance attack on the United States schools mission cherry
blossoms at night.
They attempted to launch balloons that were filled with deadly diseases like
cholera.
Smallpox in the bubonic plague is whether it's anthrax and botulism and
estimated 9,000 balloons,
web center across the Pacific Ocean,
but only 345 of them actually made it to the United States.
Many of them were shot down in some landed in the ocean or in forest.
So fields considering there were a lot of Ufo sightings at the time.
It might be possible that some people were seeing these gen buildings and
mistaking them for something else.
It was actually only one of these,
the course,
any casualties.
It landed in a town called bly,
Oregon on May the fifth,
19,
45,
a Sunday school teacher named Elsie Metro was on a day trip going on a picnic
and the mountains with a small group of our teenage students,
husbands,
archie,
who was also that minister was driving the car up the mountain.
Elsie was a few months pregnant and she got sick during the car ride.
Husband pulled over to better around to get some APP.
They had parked near a crew of men who were doing construction work on the road.
The students in llc decided to take a short walk through the woods and archie
began to speak with the men.
He then heard his wife's voice say,
look what I found.
Yeah.
Followed by an explosion lc.
You had come across one of the balloons.
She had no idea that it was actually a bomb and approaching it.
She triggered the explosion archie in the crew.
He ran towards the sounds and they found the bodies of LLC into group of
students lying dead on the ground.
Well,
most Americans were kept safe from Sherry issues,
experiments.
Those who were stationed in Asia during World War Two,
well,
they weren't so lucky in 1944 and 1945 American prisoners of war.
We're in a city called mud can.
They were visited by Japanese doctors.
Many of them had already been in captivity for several years at this point.
The Japanese wanted to see if the results were any difference on different races
and objected the men with various deadly diseases and repeated the exact
experiments that were done on the Chinese.
Many of these men died and the ones who survived were only kept around so they
could carry away the bodies of their friends
when World War Two was over,
the allied forces,
one is that they took away power from Emperor Hirohito in Manchuria.
China had defeated the Japanese as well.
There was nowhere left for issued to hide Nazi war criminals.
They were being brought to trial in Nuremberg in 1945 and 1946,
and many of them were being sentenced to death for the crimes against humanity.
The Japanese military still awarded Shero issue with medals of honor into
healthy pension for his retirement.
In their eyes,
he was a hero for the country,
but he knew that America would not feel the same,
especially once they had the stories from the POW use Shiro Ishii commanded his
doctors and soldiers to never speak of the experiments that went on in unit
7:31,
but of course they learned about the experiments through the American soldiers
who survived the American government's approached issue,
but instead of arresting him,
they asked to make a deal.
They wanted his data in exchange for immunity.
Sure is.
She knew that this was the only way he could save himself.
He promised that if they pardoned all of his crimes,
the US government could benefit from having all of the scientific information
that they had gathered from their experiments.
In the United States.
There are ethical laws in place so that American scientists are never allowed to
experiment on human beings by law.
They can only experiments on animals.
For this reason,
the government knew that these experiments were truly valuable because it was
information that they would never be able to receive on their own.
It's one thing to inject a rat or a rabbit with a disease,
but it's a totally different thing to actually know the results on human beings
and more importantly,
the Americans would gain access to the vaccines that it wishy develops some of
the deadliest diseases known to mankind.
They agreed to trade his data in exchange for his life and they even paid him
$250,000 and in modern money,
that's about two point 6 million.
All of the scientists and soldiers who were involved with unit seven,
31,
we're happy to keep the secrets because they were deeply ashamed of their
participation with a project.
Some of them even felt too ashamed to return to Japan because they were afraid
that people would learn about that.
Crime's a few of them even trying to live in China,
runs new identities.
The New York Times tried to expose this by publishing an article about is human
experiments in 1946,
but the owns that the events gains for a little media attention since all of
these atrocities happened in Nigeria,
they were technically a part of the second signer,
Japanese war,
and not World War Two.
Even though both wars were happening simultaneously for Americans,
it was overshadowed by the thousands of testimonies coming out of Europe about
the Holocaust,
but of course the Chinese people,
they have not forgotten.
Even to this day in many Chinese people still hate the Japanese for what happens
during this war.
However,
most Japanese civilians were unaware of issues,
human experiments,
and they consider themselves to be mostly victims of the war.
After the nuclear bombs were dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki,
the Japanese surrendered since there was never the chance for them to start a
massive global plague.
So what about those pow?
In the 19 forties,
governments,
officials approached them and demanded that they sign a nondisclosure contract.
They promised never to expose the truth about what had happened to them in
Manchuria.
However,
in the 19 eighties,
many of those soldiers felt that they had nothing left to lose and they came
forward to testify that they had been a part of these human experiments.
It wasn't until the 19 nineties that Japan officially acknowledged that unit
7:31 was real and it wasn't just a conspiracy theory.
Shiro Ishii Windsor live into old age and he died at the age of 67 even after
the wars were over.
That plagues that share wishy unleashed in China continue to spread and kill
people for years to come is exact number of victims is unknown.
Some estimate that he was responsible for tens of thousands,
well,
others say the number would be in the hundreds of thousands of people.
So I really hope you found that video interesting.
Just a reminder that you should check out brilliant.
You can find a link to them in the description below.
Also,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel if you liked it,
and also give us a like,
why not?
And thank you for watching.